[Music]
last week Viacom pulled its channels
from the satellite provider DirecTV over
a contract dispute okay they're having a
war
Viacom pulled its content until it's
resolved direct TV subscribers can't
watch channels like MTV Nickelodeon
Comedy Central and B et now this has
personally affected one of our writers
he asked if he could come out and talk
about it I said okay please welcome Deon
Cole
thanks Conan hey DIRECTV I want you all
to hurry up and get this resolved
I understand taking off some shows off
the network to make a stance but did you
have to take off bTW that's the only
black channel we got I'm lost without it
now I'm roaming around looking at other
channels and shows I shouldn't even be
watching like who in the hell this
Bethenny Frankel and why does she exist
I mean look you got one week DirecTV to
bring Beatty back and if you don't I'm
gonna start blackening up some shows
it's already on the air that's right
like the game of thrones it's gonna be
now game of Tyrone's
[Music]
instead of Spongebob Squarepants it it'd
be SpongeBob's saggy pan instead of you
think you can dance
it's gonna be called [ __ ] on no I
[Music]
and instead of cash cap is going to be
called how can i play this damn game if
I can't get again thank you very much
Deon Cole
I can't wait to see game of Tyrone's